January 2005 Panama Zane gray reef
world-renowned fisherman artist and
marine biologist dr. Guy Harvey and his
crew are trolling the open waters on a
mission to tag black marlin we want to
find out where these guys go after they
come through Panama which most people's
interaction with them is at the other
end of a fishing line I've just taken it
one step further the new technology has
allowed us to put a mini-computer on the
animal travel with it to give us its
precise location where it goes
guy and fellow angler bill shed are
successfully catching and tagging
400-pound Marlin when guy receives a
radio communication another world-class
fisherman Neil Patrick he's also out
fishing Marlin and he's reeling in a
whopper guy and bill are intrigued they
decide to sail over hoping to catch a
glimpse of a monster fish on his boat
Neil Patrick believes he's hooked a
world record he's already put in hours
keeping the fighting leaping Marlin on
his line I mean several it jumps where I
cleared the water completely about two
or three feet out in the water the fish
is 15 feet long so it was an impressive
sight Neil makes a momentous decision
instead of landing the Marlin for the
record he wants Guy Harvey to tag it
every angler aspires to cashing in igf a
world record at some point in their life
for Neil to have given up the chance of
possibly getting the fifty pound test
black marlin world record well it was it
was a big thing to give up
guy and bill shed pull up alongside Neil
Patrick's boat guy faces a huge
challenge beneath the waters the
fighting fish is getting dangerously
tired to tag them safely guy has to get
the Marlin to the boat fast when they
start jumping they expend a great deal
of energy in a short time and they get
tired very quickly often when they're
released they can't swim away in their
normal speed and so they become
susceptible to predictions primarily by
large shark guy hatches a daring plan to
bring the Marlin in fast as possible
he'll hook it to an additional fishing
line no fisherman's ever done this
before
with two lines attached the team can
reel it twice as fast tagging it quickly
and successfully releasing it the guy
hopes it'll work what to do it he's got
to meet this monster fish face-to-face
Donnie says well we can't bring Mohammad
to the mountain we'll take the mountain
to Mohammed here he said look I'll swim
down and attach a second line and I
thought well I didn't gonna happen but
your guy Harvey so let's try
guy hits the water he's an accomplished
swimmer but he's no match for a Marlin
fish that can easily reach speeds over
40 miles an hour most human beings can't
swim in that speed let alone wearing
diving gear swimming down with a line in
your hand 40 feet under the water trying
to catch up to this Marlin that's more
than 1,200 pounds that's not an easy
thing to do in fact that's never gonna
happen again in the history of fishing
guy makes repeated attempts the effort
is exhausting and risky every time I get
close to it previously she would kick
away again all of that is cause for
concern because it's sudden movements
like that that will cause the line to
break if the drag is too high he goes
for a final try after fighting for hours
the tired fish is slowing down at last
40 feet underwater guy approaches the
biggest Marlin he's ever seen just to be
in the company of an animal like that
this was exhilarating
working carefully guy attaches the
second fishing line by hooking it to a
metal clasp connected to Neal Patrick's
existing line the effect two fishing
poles leading to one fish I think it's
going to get tight here real quick and
then it did and the fish just took off
riffing and just to all hell broke loose
Marlin will fight to the death the team
has no time to lose
working hard they reel the immense
Marlin close to the boat to tag it
you